so lucifer i mean is lucifer over now
done it's done how do you feel about
that
it's
we did six seasons right yes i was there
from the pilot from the pilot on i mean
you were there through the cancellations
through the revivals to the you've been
through it all i don't think any show
has been canceled twice does it cancel
twice yeah
that's seldom is that and the fans got
the show back on on the air yeah
that's just incredible crazy
social media it's insane what is how do
you feel when you did your last episode
when you knew this was the end because
this is a big part of your life
big part of my life how did it affect
you
it was
it was incredibly like sad
you know to
there's a familiarity with uh
with
the lot
10 minutes from my house i sleep in my
own bed
some days i finish i can pick my kid up
from school you know just like having
that people are watching yeah people are
watching like to get on the show people
watch and really like you know yeah big
fan base and not only watch we were just
recently like
forbes were like you were the top watch
show for netflix in 2021 or something
are you serious yeah so like binge or
something so like
to i don't think you really
you know realize it
like we i didn't we had no i had no idea
what we were making until
the show was on for a few years and
then i realized when i would travel
abroad or you know
what that fan base was right because
you're you're just making this little
show in los angeles right and then you
put it out into the world and
hopefully see what happens yeah most of
the time it's a piece of [ __ ] yeah and
every once in a while you get a little
golden nugget yeah so it's you know it's
had it's had this like uh this crazy
life cycle the show um i was really sad
to
i loved our cruise and we got to do
um
we got to have crews in both vancouver
and la
and they were honestly like the backbone
of that show
because
obviously it was fun it was a fun set to
go to and and i think that was something
we were all really proud of was guest
stars wanted to come and work on the
show crew said no to jobs and hoping
that the show would get another season
you know that's that's a big compliment
and then
just you know add covet on top of that
just how much they were busting their
ass we had i mean i just hung out with
like jackie
who's my stand-in like she came over and
helped me out to walk my dogs cause i
was like jackie i need help like and
she's like i'm like let's watch a movie
let's watch bond so you know we hung out
i went on a hike with my makeup art
artist hidvig like you take these
wonderful people with you
from hungary
she's the terminator of makeup you look
beautiful darling um
so you missed the crew a lot i miss the
crew who's the one person in the cast
you're just like i miss all of them but
the one i miss is
that's it
you know it it's on your end you want to
say it but you i can't i can't say it
you can't say it i don't want to say it
how about
top no you can't say top three yeah
somebody's gonna someone's gonna be i
know i'm not even top three
what the [ __ ] are you doing here's what
i will say is
you